Former President Donald
Trump is back on the campaign trail.
And returning to a familiar playbook.
Trump speech in Waco,
Texas, was littered
with his old lies
about the 2020 election
and the border wall.
Also,
some fresh attacks
on his current legal situation as
he is facing
at least one possible indictment
that's looming
seen as Daniel
Dale joins us now with a fact check.
Daniel, I guess, you know,
one of the questions that we ask is
where do we begin?
Sometimes I feel like it's easier
to count the truths
in his speech versus the lies but
where can you take us on this?
It can be
let's let's start this time
with a wildly exaggerated
figure that former President Trump
keeps using.
Despite fact checks for me and others
for the amount of military equipment
that was left to the Taliban upon
the US withdrawal from Afghanistan.
Listen to this.
We are
a nation
that surrendered and Afghanistan,
leaving behind dead soldiers,
American citizens and $85 billion
worth of the finest military equipment
anywhere in the world.
So that 85 billion figure
is not even close to true.
The Pentagon
has put the value
of that equipment left behind
at about 7 billion.
Independent experts have told me
that makes sense.
So where does the 85 billion come from?
Well, that is a rounded figure.
It was actually about 83 billion
for the total amount of money
that Congress
appropriated
to the Afghan security forces
over the entire course of the war.
Not even close to all that gym
was for equipment.
Those things like salaries,
like infrastructure, like training.
About 19 billion
in total was equipment, about 7 billion
left behind.
Now, I'm not saying
7 billion left
behind is a good thing
before I get angry
emails from Trump supporters.
But it's important for public figures
to get their facts straight.
All right.
And you might get those emails anyway,
but Daniel,
you know,
Trump can't seem to get through the rally
these days
without lying about the border wall.
This is one that we've heard
time and again. Let's listen
I built
hundreds of
miles of wall and completed that task
totally as promised.
And then I began to add
even more wall in areas
where it was needed
Let's fact check this one.
I think I did this
after the last big Trump speech
on your show.
So, yes, again,
former President Trump
did not finish the wall
He essentially refutes his own statement
by saying it was finished
and we were building more
where it was needed.
It was still
it was still needed
because it was not done.
And we know this from official figures
released by Customs and Border Protection
right after Trump left office.
They said 480 miles had been constructed
under Trump or sorry, a four, 458 miles
completed under Trump.
But 280 remaining miles
had been identified
for wall construction, but were not done.
So having
280 miles left to go
is not even close to complete
and Mexico never paid for it.
For those of us
who were old enough to remember that one
and Trump references
legal issues, here's
what he had to say about that.
Prosecutorial misconduct
is their new tool,
and they are willing to use it at levels
never seen before.
In our country, we've had it
but we've never had it like this.
We must stop.
What's the reality on this one?
Look,
we don't know a lot about
the various investigations.
They're shrouded in secrecy.
I don't want to declare that
they're perfect investigations,
but there is no evidence
of actual prosecutorial misconduct
at this point.
So we can't say
the investigations were perfect.
President Trump
cannot say with any evidence
that there has been misconduct.
And indeed, when he makes these claims,
he does not provide
any specific corroboration,
any specific proof for any misconduct.
By any of these prosecutors. Right.
Which is what he always does.
All right.
Daniel Dale, thank you very much.
We appreciate it.